(amusing music)
- [Voiceover] OMG I can't
believe you would do that!
If you can't be my friend
then don't be my friend!
You know I'm talking to you.
- [Voiceover] Does hashtag anyone have any
hashtag cool plans for
hashtag Friday night?
Having hashtag fun hashtag today.
Hashtag I hashtag love hashtag hashtags.
- [Voiceover] This is crazy.
She can't do that.
Not again.
- [Voiceover] The good
guys win in the end.
I can't believe the main character died.
It was his father the whole time.
- [Voiceover] Lebron has now passed MJ.
Free Tom Brady.
Steph's shoes are wack.
- [Voiceover] Oh man our
summertime special is lit right now
hashtag Burrito Land.
You should whip and nae nae
over here to Burrito Land
hashtag Burrito Land.
- [Voiceover] We are
better than Burrito Land.
- [Voiceover] Delete your account.
- [Voiceover] Positivity
is always positive.
Go out and conquer today.
Never let go of your dreams.
- [Voiceover] At Honda
my AC isn't working.
At McDonald's I didn't get
a toy in my happy meal.
At Burrito Land summer time
special is not lit right now.
(amusing music)